- All right.
Welcome back, y'all.
Joining us now are Rhett and Link,
the stars of YouTube's
Good Mythical Morning.
What's up fellas?
It's nice to meet y'all.
- Hey, good to meet you.
- I hear a congrats on a 10 year.
10 year anniversary of your show, right?
- Yeah.
- A decade.
- [Kelly] That's Amazing. A decade.
That's amazing.
So explain
- That's a really long time on YouTube
- It is a long...what's a long.
A decade's a long time.
So explain the show for
those who aren't familiar.
Yes, so this is something
we do on the show.
- Okay.
- It's called naked foods.
- Yeah. So we, we thought.
- Are you ready to...
- Yes.
There's fried chickens sitting here, son.
Yes, I'm ready.
- You gonna get Naked
- [Rhett] And it's getting cold.
- [Link] You gonna get Naked
for some fried chicken?
I'm gonna get naked for some
not getting naked, but...
- That's not how it works.
- Basically,
like these are from three
different price levels, right?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So we're trying to figure out
what our price or what
our taste really costs.
So we're gonna taste
these and each one of us
are gonna decide which
one we like the best
and we're gonna find out one's cheap,
one sort of middle price
and one is more expensive.
- Yeah. Grocery store level,
sit down restaurant
and then fine dining.
- Okay.
So, when it comes to fried chicken.
Let's let taste be our guide.
We've stripped everything else away.
It's naked.
- [Kelly] Okay. It's naked.
I like it.
Let's do it.
So let's start it from left to right.
Are you ready?
- [Rhett] Yep.
- I'm not using a fork and a knife.
They probably want me to, but
I'm just getting in there.
- [Link] Yeah, that's the
okay, you gotta taste a biscuit too.
That'll wash down the bone.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- Biscuits a little bit.
This feels like maybe
from the frozen section.
I don't know.
I mean, I like it and I
would finish it, but..
- It's like crunchy outside.
- [Rhett] I'm not super thrilled about it.
- [Link] Speaking of
crunchy, let's move to...
- Okay, the next middle.
Alright.
- This one is bringing the crunch.
- Okay. I like crunch.
You guys think it's so crunchy.
I didn't even get the meat yet.
( audience laughing)
- And that meat is really moist.
- [Kelly] Really moist.
- This is done really, really well.
This, this is probably
fancy, but don't let that
- I think there's a fancy flavor in there.
- There is something there's
some kind of flavor hat.
- What is that Spice? A little cumin?
- [Kelly] I don't know what that is.
- I usually just say Cumin
when I can't think of another spice.
- It is like, it sounds fancy.
- It sounds Smart.
It's a cumin.
- [Link] All right.
- Last one.
Okay.
- Now this thigh, breast.
- Yeah.
This is a leg.
Oh, that!
- it's got green flex on It.
- [Kelly] It does.
- What is...
I've never seen green
flex on a fried chicken.
- That signifies fancy to me.
- Cumin, Cumin
- It's cumin.
Okay.
- The chicken's okay.
The biscuits square.
- [Kelly] I like the biscuits.
Okay.
So wait, now we pick our favorite.
- Now you just, on a count of three,
you just put your flag in the breast.
- Are you allowed to move things around?
If you like something from another place?
- No.
- That is against the rules.
- [Kelly] Okay.
You will be kicked out.
- Vapor plucks the chicken together.
- Okay. Okay.
- Three, two, one.
- Boom!
- I'm in the middle.
Me and Kelly are in the middle.
- Middle.
- Okay. Let's find out
where these are from.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
We correctly planted some flags.
- [Rhett] Yes.
- Okay, So this one on the left.
This was grocery store.
- [Rhett] Yeah.
- Hey, I didn't find a bag.
- Yeah, that's fine.
That's fine.
Grocery store.
We can put some middle in.
- Fried chicken brings it all.
- [Kelly] okay.
- I'm not gonna apologize.
- Wait, what about the middle one?
What's the middle one?
Casual restaurant.
- Oh, just casual.
- This is, that's me.
I'm very casual restaurant.
- We're not getting ahead of ourselves.
We're not going full square biscuit.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- [Rhett] We wouldn't do that.
- Don't get crazy.
So then the last one
is the fine dining one,
obviously with the green.
- How much was that?
- Fine dining.
- You gotta pay $42 for a square biscuit.
- I know, but this is, and I
will say the biscuit was good
if I could have, I would've
switched the biscuits
but this chicken was really good.
- Yeah. Listen, I think
that the big lesson here
is nobody here has gotten
too far from the roots.
- Exactly.
I love that I totally nailed
down the middle casual
and I totally thought I would.
(everyone laughs)
You can't hide your roots.
All right.
This is the most delicious
game I've ever played.
Thank you so much, fellas.
Gentlemen, this is so awesome.
You're welcome back anytime.
You can catch a new episode
of Rhett and Link show,
Good Mythical Morning on
their YouTube channel.
Monday to Friday.